[Musique]
il ya quelque chose de merveilleux qui
se passe à ce moment il y à un nouveau
génération qui qui a cassé tous les
tabous ont brisé les maladies d'amérique
l'argent surtout l'argent et encore
l'argent c'est un génération qui s'en
fout de l'argent
le voilà en france en 68
tout ce que je voyais c'était les
étudiants les ouvriers ont suffisamment
grand nombre a failli renverser le
gouvernement
et ça me semblait merveilleux je dois
dire
[Musique]
j'ai vu tous les problèmes comme des
problèmes isolés la guerre une erreur de
notre part
le racisme notre problème le chômage
notre problème et au cours de ce voyage
j'ai commencé à voir que il y as un
problème tout et que tous ces choses là
sont des résultats du problème de fond
qui est notre système ici en amérique
mais actuellement ce que je veux c'est
de travailler en collectif de faire des
films politiques
peut-être pas toujours quand je dis
politique je ne peux pas dire des films
documentaires avec une massage qui tape
sur la tête et jean ça peut aussi
peut-être être des films des comédies
des musicales des films de spectacles
[Musique]